i used to work at iowa used to work at
iowa yeah i waited tables at tempe yeah
i'd bring out the sampler platters with
my thumb and the yoke and
like here you go yeah here you go
steve lost his job quick yeah i got
fired from that
pf changs got firefighters get fired
from pfj i got fired
that's why i love it here king in the
stinging kingdom
back off my broccolini get your life
together
it is don't touch me bro i'm not
touching you dude
[Music]
you seen his daughter though what's
going on here steve yeah you're a little
too into that dog
a little too into that dog dog no i like
this dog
have you seen steve harvey's daughter
though no
bro bro really bravo
her man's michael b jordan oh well there
you go yeah
that tells you enough yeah yeah yeah
like i don't even need to know what she
looks like
that isn't that funny that it's that way
like if it doesn't work the other way
no you better you know like if we don't
know even what if i'm saying it for like
if it's like
if you go oh pick a hot chick and you go
she's with whoever i would need just i
couldn't assume he's handsome
cause cause girls aren't like us no
they're it's not like there's a big
personality yeah yeah
yeah i need to see that because look at
me i totally get that
but if you go you know the opposite way
yeah michael b
jordan's not rolling fives you know
[ __ ] he ain't rolling with eight no hell
no
there's some eights out there that need
some work why steve's getting licked by
this dog and i'm really enjoying it i'm
just
i'm just petting the dog what's going on
in your knee there
yeah what are you a peanut butter on
there yeah
you got the legs out today daddy yeah i
showered and
i there's nothing weird yeah what are
you doing what are you showering with
um shampoo
resume that's the great endorsement
yeah is it the family bottle is it the
all-in-one like
body wash conditioner i don't do that i
don't run that
thank you because that's ridiculous yeah
i don't do that brandon i don't trust
people that use that yeah yeah they're
all involved
no you're talking about the body wash
man yeah
[Laughter]
is good like why use some like it's sort
of natural
so it's not a roll-on i have to like get
a little boom
are you worried about like the aluminum
it has like no but just this
deodorant works well old spice is great
yeah i have fights with i thought the
bear glove bear
they have they have the animal series
bear glove then the wolf one
i know i don't know yeah it smells kind
of fruity like great kind of like a
different does your girl pick your
cologne
she does she's got an allergy to that
kind of stuff so i don't really wear
a degree is good too degree cold rush is
good if i do it'd be like a little bit
you know but oh she like if you do it
like she'll be like it's too much
that's how my dad is what are you guys
you guys selling some designer shampoos
um whatever she puts in there
you know exactly you don't go shopping
for your own stuff
for cologne and deodorant i do but like
oh you were cologne yeah oh yeah
what kind of clone you wearing well
that's the like what because what are
you what what's your
ethnic mix again uh what do you think
italian right you got some
italian english italian yeah oh there's
no persian in there no
i know right yeah because i don't get
that then i would understand yeah
you know armenia look you've got to look
though you probably get that a lot yeah
you're just not you but you're not hairy
so that's why
people figure it out we should do your
23 on me on here
have you ever done it yeah i have i have
it on my phone yeah
oh was it were you were you shocked by
it
uh no because i know my mom was born and
raised in england she like grew up there
so i was like 50 english
and then i was higher italian i thought
i was like 18 italian i thought it was
like a
splash of like three percent oh wow i
don't even want to do it
you could do a test now you don't want
to know no i don't want to know i don't
want to i just well you go to
ancestry.com you know you could do a
saliva blood test and they could do
exactly
what we're talking about the same thing
yeah same thing because we're i'm 10
japanese i didn't know i had japanese
blood oh no
yeah my brother bob found that out in
hawaii and my mom had a mental breakdown
like she she like flipped out she was
like oh no how how did the japanese get
in there i don't know i mean
someone has some explaining to do poppy
what i mean okinawa
i mean back in the day on some mystery
like okinawa it's like finding out if
you're a part of the clan and then you
find out you know you're 10 percent
black
yeah i have no problem with that kind of
thing yeah it's batman i have no problem
with it but you know like old school
koreans because of the war
you know that's what i'm saying because
in history world war ii and all that
something happened though there were
love affairs obviously like just because
governments don't like you so many
people can't fall in love like my great
great great great like grandmother
yeah something happened yeah that was
probably something japanese guy that was
like what's up girl
for sure
[Laughter]
that's what happened and somebody fell
in love with like back in the day like
white slave owners they had a bunch of
mixed babies it's like
yeah because some of the slaves you're
talking about some beautiful black women
of course they're sleeping with the men
and there's like a ton of babies came
from horrible stuff went down then
and i'm sure maybe it wasn't something
terrible i mean like because that
situation like you know we were just
we're just hoping it wasn't something
like you know
oh no you know but but hopefully it was
consensual yeah
i'm sure but someone probably fell in
love with them yes i'm sure yeah
yeah you know what happens what's this
gentleman saying oh okay we got can you
understand it he's got our first debate
club for us
i can't believe you don't want to know
what you're no because it's like yeah
i've lived so long it's like like what
is it gonna at this point what is it
gonna
tell me like what is it to change i just
had this thing i think p
people spend too much time worrying
about your race gender
sexual orientation they worry they worry
so much about that and their answer to
that stuff should be
who cares yeah and then they tie their
identity yeah yeah then you tie your
identity to that so then you become like
it's like no matter what they tie it to
it so like you're
the ufc fighter comic you're always
gonna be that you're always gonna be
tied to the ufc no matter what
right so sometimes that's okay and other
times it's like when somebody's like
when somebody's gay or somebody
something like that then it's like
whatever you do you become
the gay that yep or you become the
whatever that and it's like
who cares yeah well you could just find
out and then just go on
like like you could just do the test
real quick be like all right
you would know at this point it's like
what you can tell something i was going
to do this show
it was like there was this reality show
this lady was producing and she was
telling me her story so she wanted it to
be like i would be the host and then
you watch people do these tests and then
they find out things that they didn't
know and the reason why she did it was
because wanted to do this because
in her own story she did it and then she
found out like
let's say she was like german and
english yeah but
one of her parents wasn't either one of
those oh damn you know so then she went
to them like
you want to tell me something you
adopted and it turns out
you know it turns out her mother wasn't
her real mother oh damn
and it's the reason why she's had this
contention with her mother her whole
life
she realizes and it's like oh this is
because we all got stories
you know it's like we've lived a full
life before we have
kids that's one thing like if you were
to adopt a kid right now
like it was an infant infant and he was
real small would you tell him that he
was adopted when he gets older
i feel like it just creates drama no
they have the right to know though man
but why why they would know like if i
adopted a korean baby then it would be
like
that's different baby i'm like no what
are you talking about i'm just
saying but that's what i'm saying is you
can't always find like the baby that you
want a baby what i'm saying let's say
because you want a white baby right
you're gonna adopt a baby i'll be down
for whatever
okay well if that's the case you would
have to tell them yeah but let's say
that's the reason why you told me let's
say if it was a white baby and look
like similar to me maybe you don't tell
them yeah but you think he's not living
with all that bad
interesting question yeah do you tell
them you would adopt a korean baby
oh i'd be down for whatever you would
really get one of mine yeah i mean
korean babies are cute as [ __ ]
you take care of it yeah yeah we get one
of the girls before they throw them in
the river
wait wait wait what is that no hospital
what is that
yeah isn't that a thing over there that
was the old school they were
talking population you don't control
a certain amount of girls in your family
that's china man
oh so sorry this is different asian
country hold up man chin back me up
brother i'm used to this back me up
brother
yeah wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait racism so that's not
that means we need to get a chinese baby
not a korean baby you guys are doing
chinese baby
you guys are just mixed up yeah yeah we
just mixed up the ones
does korea have a policy like that at
all no there's no population
except for like at the iphone factory
because we went to australia together on
tour i barely knew chin he came with me
and i didn't realize in australia
they're it's like they're vegas
like so many americans so many others
are really asian
when they go there for education yeah
and they're buying stuff off i was like
damn
and i'm like look at all these chinese
people jim like dude they're japanese
i'm like oh my bad
look at all these japanese like dude
they're korean by the end of the trip
though i got it
you could figure out yeah well you can
tell the difference you know what it's
like you know what it's like
i was around have you ever known twins
you know yeah and then like
you they're identical okay identical
twins right but once you see
what the thing is that makes them
different you could never
unsee it never yeah that's the same
thing with like you know it's like
mexican el salvadorian guatemalan
honduran that's all your puerto rican
it's like it's all the same kind of
thing
you're like my girl like latin music's
blown up right
and i'd be like oh like carol g's dope
like she's like cute she's like the nicu
she's so big in the latin culture and
i'll go uh she's mexican my girl's like
bro she is not mexican man
she's uh i forget what she is colombian
beautiful colombians but the best yeah
stevie
but then brazil too oh you always know
that you're just looking at them
but then when you check the booty you
can find out they're from brazil
yeah all short sorts of asses but the
just the latin like the way they say
things now i can pick
up colombian whatever oh really yeah all
right what's up
king of the sting fam you know movement
has expanded
into blue light glasses that protect
your eyes from screens you might know
movement for their dope watches but now
they even expanded more they have
movement
blue light glasses to protect those eyes
from the screens you're always staring
at and on july 20th movement is
celebrating their eight year anniversary
by running a huge statewide sale every
single thing is 28
off that's 28 off all their best-selling
watches
blue lights glasses jewelry and so much
more
all right movement is going all out for
their eighth birthday it's their biggest
sale of the year take advantage of these
price points before they go
celebrate eight years of movement that's
28 off
site wide at mvmt.comcats
don't miss movement's biggest sale of
the year go to mvmt.com
cats join the movement hey y'all i see a
lot of you bros at the shows
i see a lot of theos fans losing their
hair trying to grow out that mullet like
the rat king and it ain't working
it ain't working because you need to do
something about your hair piece did you
know two out of three bros will
experience some form of hair loss
by the time they're 35 yep more than 50
million men in the us of a suffer from
male pattern baldness
keeps is here to help keeps offers a
simple stress free way
to keep your hair alright it's low cost
treatments start at just ten dollars per
month and keeps offers
generic versions of the best stuff
discreet packaging
shows up so nobody needs to know you're
trying to get your hair right
prevention is key treatments can take
four to six months to see results so act
right now
if you're ready to take action prevent
your hair from leaving
go to keeps.com kats that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com
slash k-a-t-s to receive your first
month of treatment for
free that's keeps.com cats k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash cats is this true are
brazilian women do they like smaller men
i heard that is that a rumor some
brazilian we should should find
you that no i heard that these brazilian
women
like the ones with the booties they like
smaller men oh wait i'm watching the
wrong pornos then
[Laughter]
dude have you heard of ethical porn
no what are you talking about mind
blowing
you saw that last night there's a thing
called ethical porn what's that dang it
and it's me
a lot of it is made by women okay so
it's like it's all passionate
yeah yeah it's all about them you know
that's like it's really interesting
physical porn look at that how do i
watch it how do i check it out you know
there's
there's ethical porn science is it a
category yeah they get paid more
it looks like in all different types of
shapes and sizes so it's not always
just some sexy mom on there they get
paid fairly it's like it's this whole
kind of like hey if
this is like if you don't beat them join
them and do it right that's cool
right yeah ethical porn so if you look
at some of the things it's like you know
it's like
kind of positions you don't see a lot of
times in porn like the
boring one yeah you know the guy is
going down on her
bro but it's just like it's very
interesting
that that kind of stuff is going on out
there nothing like that it shows real
sexual
pleasure it's created for all kinds of
viewers bro stevie blew my mind he said
on twitch
look it shows diverse across body size
race sexual age and ability ability to
heart our ability
oh so you have a micro penis and do it
apparently
not into that at all dude but there's a
lane for it i like how you looked over
at chin
he knew but he didn't rest on him you
can have a micro penis
chin
[Music]
we heard steve's packing stop that's why
this dog was like
don't throw the dog in the middle stevie
blew my mind he said on uh you know
twitch better than probably anybody in
here
he was saying on twitch people are
paying to watch a girl sleep sleep
streaming
yeah well they have they have um yeah
nobody have sleeping they have hot tub
streams they have like you know
dude just first of all are you really
surprised that you could take a hot girl
and put her in any situation or people
will pay to watch it was she just
sleeping yeah she's sleeping man getting
paid
yeah hey god wow yeah good for them
yeah let's talk about not interfering
with your work day either right
[Laughter]
how about quitting your job like how are
you making money i just sleep
people watch me sleep see there's one
right here hot tub stream right there
there's that girl
tip stream makes sense though they're in
bikini yeah yeah yeah
but these gamers these gamer guys are
like confused with themselves anyway
they don't know what's going on i get it
first hot touch stream can men have only
fans and twitch just like
yeah those guys aren't only fans is
there yeah yeah there's there's the gay
portion
then there's people that do like just
stuff but it's just not the ones that
people hype up but they're not making 20
g's a month 20k a month just playing
warzone
well there are people that do that yeah
there's that st stevie
on twitch yeah these guys make a lot of
money playing games
ninja ninja oh there's like and nick
mercs bro i'm with this yeah they're
making hundreds of thousands of dollars
a month yeah
me and nick burke yeah pretty similar
shout out to nick marks
yeah uh ninja we have the same merch guy
and uh i was like man who's your top
seller like oh not even
close ninja yeah and i look and like
look at the stuff i go in the back
there's just
tons of his merch i mean dope [ __ ] yeah
nick works i think nick marks is into
like
200 300 000 a month a month yeah playing
like just video games yeah they play
he plays warzone a lot or is he good he
must be good though oh yeah
you have to be yeah yeah those people
those people are like he's like
he's like a 30 kill a game guy that's
impossible
you can't get 30 kills that's why you're
not you're a big boss it's awesome
stevie didn't know that steven didn't
know you played
oh they're basically pros though that's
why they're making so much money yeah
yeah
they're great you know how much effort
it takes to get that many
just one kill well that's why it's
making you have to watch their video you
have to watch their game play it's it's
crazy
and i know they're driving they're going
that some girls are doing the most on
there he's like i thought i was just
like
no no dude are you kidding me that thing
is full see there's a certain
i don't because i haven't joined i know
about it i haven't enjoyed it i don't
get it i don't even get it
look there's a certain voyeurism to it
that what it's about
is that the fact that you believe that
this is that's a real person
they're real they're not like uh it's
not porn so they're
real it's not highly produced so you
feel this like sort of like
intimate connection with this person and
you they're sending you something
private so i get to get that thing so
it's funny because i have a friend of
mine that is on only fans and she don't
even run it
i was just laughing about that you know
so she's somebody's picture she just
sends the pics and somebody runs it and
it's messaging with the people yeah
no and you know what there's a certain
risk because you know what i never
understand why you can't look on
the internet google like you know only
fans pictures
so that's another thing that people
aren't doing too they're not you know
paying for it and then
like posting the pictures sharing it
sharing it well no because i feel like
there's like a respect thing i mean i
don't know i'm surprised though i'm
surprised too
while the thorn stuff wasn't all over
the internet i had a friend who
uh was doing only fans and then these
haters were posting the pictures
oh see it's from but then you can hire
an agency that pulls all that down and
can pull
that entire like thread down so if you
do post it like it's illegal
it's not like pornhub where you don't
need to be a member like who's a who's
who's got a membership like what kind of
kind of crazy person are you savage
you're savage if you're like you know
what i mean what more could you want
what more like there's
everything on there man yeah i know i
was on it last night
you're on there late last night what
happened to old philly dove up in
washington i'm just
you know like you know it's a lot of
effort when you do stuff like that you
know
you get on a plane yeah well just you
know i just i'll keep it old school
you have came to watch this i'm in
tacoma she does she live close to tacoma
yeah close enough close enough yeah cuz
he came to show with her a little date
night
yeah well you know i'm okay with my porn
right now
oh wow so it's not going well all right
what's this guy saying like no
look i told you already steve's a simple
guy yeah it's like that's a lot of that
word and it's like why
you know and you get a you know there's
a lot of things i need in place like i
need to get a car
yes i need to move into you know better
spot
there's a lot of things nothing's wrong
with your spot yeah really no he wants
to upgrade his level
i want to upgrade i like come on i get
it like when a chick comes over he
doesn't want her to be like
oh what am i sleeping back
what's up i mean many people come in
here and they're just like
okay all right
dude don't shoot me punch don't do that
he's just an asian partner
he's so great about steve's place please
don't do that steve
steve's ac is in the bathroom
there we go wait wait wait and
it's like when you sit on this toilet
the hd is like
like you can't you have to like you have
to go like this you know what i mean
because the ac
dude i allowed you to take a [ __ ] in my
apartment
man don't make fun of my ac unit man
there's no other place for anything you
pulled the other place through it
by steve that's why you're saying i want
him to upgrade
he wants to upgrade him yeah now yeah
it's been a little too nice about my
spot
dude i enjoyed it i thought it was cozy
i think you're being a little bit too
nice
deep down you're like he could help me
no not at all like if you took his place
and put it at like
a northridge dorm right
it would be like then you go okay all
right dude
so you're just saying my permit's like a
dorm room yeah
yeah is it amazing like a gamer's door
man it's like a gamer
cave is a big word it's not necessarily
a cave it's not a man
all right dude that's enough man like a
beaver would be like all right
you're painting you're painting it's
okay
you know what it's authentically you
have you got any complaints about it
from the ladies stevie
no but uh you know i need to get a new
comforter you know i don't have
the i got my comforter at target you
know target pockets got good comforters
okay so you know i need to get better
stuff first of all they're not going to
come like it's not like the girl comes
first the girl already wants to be with
him yeah they already got a connection
she's going to his place and if they
don't know each other that well she
knows the deal
yeah so when she gets there even if she
doesn't like the place she's like okay
let me just get this over with and i'm
not going to like
lunch boxes and toys and yeah like
stickers you know
it's just like if they come
if they say something then then they
have a problem with it but you know
seems like what are
these little trinkets and [ __ ] on them
yeah yeah i need to it's
it's not like you lying you go hey you
come by my place you tell them right you
go listen i got a small place
yeah in and out burger i mean i always
yeah you're like going in and out
there's a there's a ihop down the street
i'm sure
he
how many times have we gone to ihop a
lot all right okay i'm sure
that and you didn't even put out i used
to work there i used to work at iowa i
used to work at iowa yeah i waited
tables at tempe yeah
i'd bring out the sampler platters with
my thumb and the yoke and
like here you go yeah here you go yeah
steve lost his job quick
yeah i got fired from that pf changs got
fired got fired from pfj oh
i got fired that's why i love it here
king in the stinging kingdom
that's what we're doing
i'm all for the the slogans okay here we
go all right
give it to us okay my name is jury i'm
from orange county
i'm not too far from you guys um and i
got a debate club for you guys
um the olympics are here and i want to
know what you guys think what's better
the winter olympics or
you know we got the summer olympics but
what you guys think i know i know what
theo is probably going to say i know you
know he has a lot of experience with uh
snow so i hope this isn't too triggering
for you theo
but um let me know what you guys think
and um i'm not too far from la so if you
guys need anybody um
help with the podcast hit your boy up
peace out there's already one big bro in
here you know that was actually a good
question man
is it have you been watching have you
been watching dude
women's soccer dude all that well they
got their ass with that first game
they took a knee and got that ass do you
see that simon
uh what's her name simone biles she
she's just
in this it's gonna this is dicey so
you know she's like the goat of
gymnastics she's like
the michael jordan gymnastics did she
get injured dude no she didn't get
injured she said she needed a mental
break and just
told the team i'm out she said
almost like she just yeah yeah and then
told it and then
and they've won like 11 years you know
eleven has that
ever happened in the history of them
never am i thinking that's this is
historical yeah but she's been to the
olympics this is what isn't this her
like third olympics
third or fourth so she's like she's like
20 you might be
over it yeah yeah yeah but my thing is
and you know i know mental illness is a
big
uh oh goddammit oh have you ever seen
that live
have you ever been on a j i mean the
pressure so
little the time like the the uneven bars
like the leaderboards you think like oh
wow that's up way up in the air until
you see the coach step in
yeah and the [ __ ] is like yeah yeah is
that coach the hound
like how big is that [ __ ] coach yeah
the coach is six foot well listen man i
mean i think that it's like
it is what it is i i don't even i like i
don't know i don't necessarily feel bad
for her
in a sense that she goes she's making a
choice for herself she went through this
who i feel bad for is the person that
that is not there that could be there
because she took that spot and doesn't
really want to be there i feel bad for
that person
and i also but no i don't want to i do
feel bad but like if she's going through
something
you know i hope she gets the help that
she needs
but it's like yo but you knew the job
was dangerous when you took it there's
my thing it's like
i get it mental health is a thing now
it's once every four years and you're
also a professional like i'm sure
there's nothing you get
there's nights when michael jordan feel
like playing i'm sure there's nights you
don't feel like doing stand-up when
you're on your fifth show
yeah yeah bro people paid and you're a
professional
yeah so that's what separates
professional from amateurs
you're not gonna feel great and also the
team is depending on you it's once every
four years
not only that there's so much pressure
that event man that's what you said
because they grow up as
kids well she's already been there she
knows the pressure she's getting
the goat does she got like ten gold
medals or something she's like most gold
medals ever yeah so it's like she's
already been married do you think the
was it a mental thing or did the
pressure get to her like i don't think
he's the president one of the two
i think she's just she's like the most
famous olympian it sounds like she's
over it
and there's no audience either so i'm
sure it sucks to be because you could
feed off that energy
there's nothing like it's like zoom
olympics yeah she's like [ __ ] dude
i did skateboarding this year yeah
yeah no japanese yuto origami [ __ ]
japanese yeah
he beat out niger and all them damn yeah
this kid's a prodigy man
protege i mean yeah i wonder when
they're gonna have like
gaming in the olympics no that's gonna
happen in the near future for sure
it's next one well they just want
ratings will the chinese dominate that
oh yeah
well the child or who's the best i don't
know who's the best right chin yeah
they're here
but americans kick ass too right like we
have all the leaks
and [ __ ] but i mean i don't even follow
gaming but i always see like headlines
japan and korea dude
wins they have teams well you know i
think that they're
they need to get back to being in person
because they're really having an
issue with you know they have a lot of
these online tournaments where you know
you can join a tournament play like war
zone for instance and you can play
a tournament the problem is it's like
the cheating is so rampant
oh yeah so there's no integrity in the
game oh because it's all online yeah
so people have this and they're enabling
it now there's a free uh program where
they're like hey this cheap program's
for free
have you heard about this yeah man it's
crazy so they could wall hack they could
see you through walls
they could like head glitch onto your
head like damn but i think it's
i think it's set in back esports though
is what i'm saying for sure
it's setting it back because these like
devices you can also add to your
controller it's called a cronus device
is that an anti-cheat like no no no no
it's uh it's you can
it's not just pc people cheating no no
no no no no no no there's comments
that's what i'm saying it's like it's
called a cronus and you can hook it up
to the the
the controller and it does all the same
kind of thing it's an aimbot it takes
away all the
things so what i'm saying that was like
pd but before the pandemic you know
esports was getting
huge man it was like people were filling
arenas and watching people there were
leagues and stuff staples
you can't do that stuff from home you
get
because they can't control the equipment
yeah i don't understand what's the
purpose of playing when you're cheating
though like the what's the fun of that
a lot of people are doing it control a
lot of people are doing it control now
it's like
just doing something like the audience
members hey laugh at you know i can tell
you why
like like you know you look from a rod
himself he was saying you know
once you sign a huge contract a lot of
pressure there's a lot of pressure to
live up to that and if you can't live up
to that that's why a professional
while you're cheating use steroids so
what i'm saying is oh that's a good
example
what i'm saying is like so in in this
world like i would not be surprised like
there was a big tournament you know who
i had on my podcast
you know jay god is i've heard of him
yeah he's uh he's a
stat geek and he's like big in the
warzone world well i had him on my
podcast
he gave you some stuff and he was just
telling me about like you know
that well i saw a video of his where he
was there was a big hundred thousand
dollar tournament what and one of the
people in the tournament
turned out to be cheating and how did
they catch him though because they have
they
they had to have people watching his
game play that's him yeah
you know why they're cheating because
there's money involved that's what i'm
saying yeah so that's my point
i'm saying it's like it's such a bit
what i'm what i'm saying is that's
taking away the integrity of the game
and like activision themselves have you
heard about what's going on with
activation no but i know man
look at the activision scandal [ __ ]
creek wants battlefield no no no no but
steve this is something completely
different
activision is in trouble in their
offices for sexual harassment
and uh they got a california is suing
them you know
so they're you know so they're they got
that's right up the street this whole is
they're having a bunch of issues uh you
know
dude that's but i'm not surprised
actually because they're abusive to us
you know they are they are allowed to
have anti-cheat man they're
okay last night i swear to god i was by
a container's tent
a control center and i was literally had
i was shooting this guy with my craig
he literally went and then i just do
they have that was the last i could have
won
but he went oh and then just he did yeah
but this guy's telling me he was
cheating there's not going to be
anti-cheats because the anti-cheats on a
pc is
too intrusive so like to have a true
anti-cheat it would need your computer
to let this program
open up your whole thing so we can see
what other programs are running
and people just don't want to do that oh
hell no people are not going to be like
i'm not letting you into my
surprise what they do they won't cheat a
hundred percent of the time
they'll selectively cheat that's what's
hard
oh you know i'm missing some shots or
you know what i mean people that when
people are watching them
yeah then then when they need the kill
they'll they'll they'll make it whatever
is involved yeah that's what's happening
but there's actually there's actually
clans out there steve
that are all cheaters they're cheating
on purpose damn clan you know you know
what they do
and what they do at the end at the end
of the game steve at the end of the game
they drop all their guns and let the
other person win wow they do it they do
it
like hey man we're cheating you win yeah
yeah you know man who doesn't want
instant gratification if you're looking
for satisfaction there's no need to wait
with credit karma money
you could win cash reimbursements for
debit purchases
you spend anyway why not make a little
bank bro credit karma money is a brand
new checking account where you can win
cash reimbursements for making purchases
you're gonna do it anyways man
why not use credit karma when you use
credit karma money debit card
you can win daily instant karma purchase
reimbursements on items up to 5 000
buckaroos just pay with your debit card
and if you win you'll be notified on the
spot with instant karma cash
will be added right back in your spend
account open your fdic insured
spend account for free there's no
minimum balance requirements no
overdraft fees
and free withdrawals from a network of
over 50 000
atms credit karma money progress starts
here
right now visit creditkarma.com win
money to open your free account and
start winning instant karma
go to creditkarma.com win money to sign
up for
free start winning instant karma that's
creditkarma.com
win money insane karma sponsored by
credit karma no purchase necessary
exclusions term supplies see rules
banking service provided by mvb bank
incorporated
member fdic maximum balance and transfer
limit supply again
credit karma.com win money you know it
turns out everything you think you know
about
probiotics may be wrong all right i know
it might be wrong
good news seeds daily symbiotic
is the real deal holy feel looking for a
way to ease bloating you're not alone
facts two out of three americans live
with digestive discomfort including
bloating
prolonged fullness you got doodoo issues
seed is working to change all that
fact many probiotics can survive the
trip to your gut
good news good news if those pro
probiotics can't survive good news is
seeds daily symbiotic
can and does all right so
so if you're ready seed it's a day what
you got you're like what's a daily
symbiotic what is it
the broad spectrum two in one probiotic
prebiotic we got you covered man
uh what does it do for you it supports
benefits in and beyond the gut including
uh
your skin health heart health gut immune
function
all right we got it all covered for you
vitamins b
9 b12 many see improvements in digestion
within 24 hours to 48 hours which can
include
them due to movements all right and
we're gonna ease bloating for you so
if you're ready to start a new healthy
habit today visit seed.com
kats use the code kats to redeem 20
off your first month at seeds daily
symbiotic
that's seeds.com cats and use the code
k-ats
i love seeds because listen i took it
and you know i was ready to go in 24
hours i woke up the next morning
boom never felt better no bloating none
of that man
just got another debate club for us hey
guys my name is kara i'm from tampa
florida
and i have a debate club for you what's
a better game show
wheel of fortune or family feud
personally i love wheel of fortune
i watch it every single night and it's
my biggest dream to be on the show
i'm looking at you pat and vanna so what
do you guys say
wheel of fortune or family feud gang
gang
buzz buzz she just uh
she's she just used this to put a shout
out to you know
it's kind of like what steve and
jeremiah did yeah all right for scissor
brothers
hey i'm not wearing this i'm wearing a
normal shirt today
i learned from my i'm sorry by the way i
like summer olympics better than winter
olympics never even answered that
question
i love this summer summer all day winter
olympics i'm just like
just you're just waiting for somebody to
die the bobslen you know i mean anytime
they come down to
that i'm just waiting is he going to die
uh wheel of fort got this at like will
who's like what was it
what young kids watching wheelchair
family or family feud family feud or
real fortune
oh man i like family feud just depending
like because steve harvey makes it fun
well good answer yeah yeah yeah family
feud for me too yeah
he loves asking a really leading
question and then being shocked when
it's semi-dirty but it's like oh i know
sometimes i don't know why they don't
just go you know the top ten holes
to put something in yeah 100 people here
and then somebody goes butthole let's
see how we go
yeah top ten holes put something steve
like okay
yeah yeah like oh like he doesn't know
already like they didn't go over it
backstage
but i actually thought we could play
some family feud
um and we've set up the game christian
you can go in there now
oh now i get it that's why it looks like
steve harvey's pocket
yeah except he won't be talking he'll
just how does the game work again it's
just categories
yeah you gotta guess like what's gonna
be in the category yes where'd you get
that suit from portuguese that's great
doesn't it
honestly this is the only suit i own i
bought it oh nice
yeah gianni's coming to townsend yeah
yeah
and you wrecked his car well someone
else wrecked him
don't hit me so talk loud if uh if you
speak
uh yeah someone did wreck my i didn't
wreck it someone crashed into me so
therefore
they wrecked it but yeah either way my
boy johnny doesn't have a car when he's
in l.a no he does and he found i didn't
know you didn't tell him
no i talked to johnny on time like damn
dog sex without your cars like the [ __ ]
out of my car like
oh talk to your brother yeah yeah you're
going through this week
yeah i [ __ ] you also he also got
breaking news that your
mom had a heart attack from me i didn't
know
i was like damn so sorry about your mom
he goes i'm on set what's wrong with my
mom i was like
talk to you talk to your brother oh
you're the
worst i i dude i thought it was family
you're the
word he told me this guy's he'll be like
oh sorry your chicks getting an abortion
i saw her at the clinic he's like
what
uh so how do we want to split up teams
uh uh
i think it's stevie chin eric and
brendan will be the ones playing
how do we want to split these up and
then we've got a cat's fan it wouldn't
be like that it would be like the chin
family hey man
okay cool so so they're gonna be like uh
just
uh
can i need the word the origin of that
word yeah they're gonna be used in a
sentence
they're just saying a spelling bee this
ain't a spelling bee
yeah but you're gonna be you're gonna
win if there's a spelling bee so it's
the weebies versus the
are you guys the griffins or the shots
the the shipments
the shiffens that we sound jewish the
chiffons yeah we're super jewish
and here's our first contestant it was
actually the girl who suggested the
the topic this is kara oh she's back oh
damn what's so good
is she live is this live uh this is live
oh wow you surprised us with something
what's up girl good luck getting on
wheel of fortune yeah oh come on do you
guys know uh
pat urbana no eric hi hello
oh damn hello i like how you said that
just just a second hello
hi brandon hey i just wait hold on
definitely hi brendan
no i didn't mean it like that what about
steve
just saw you in tampa a couple months
ago oh nice good to see you
yeah my boyfriend and i we came to see
you
let's just move on let's move on
boyfriend boyfriend
we're not listening to you anymore all i
hear is
what do you got for us girl yeah i have
i'm coming to tampa actually
uh in a couple months champion improv no
uh
side splitters i'll go to side splitters
all right girl what do you got for us
i saw um
dylan i saw tim dillon twice yeah he's a
monster i saw him twice within like two
months at side splitters
he even makes fun of side splitters and
he's like we know we're in florida when
y'all come to a comedy show
in a strip mall you're right
it's a nice i like you know it's a new
owner now is it different yeah but uh
she's gonna be on uh
chin and stevie's team she doesn't have
a question for us oh okay and then we've
got another person
this is uh and then we'll let you know
when it's your turn kara and then this
is
tyler tyler got screwed he sent in a
video for
uh the girl with the dating game and uh
and then we didn't let him into the oh
you gotta let him in man let him
in i know he's in now okay welcome to
the squad we're the bro squad
what's up y'all how y'all doing what's
up man so
um kara you're on with stevie and chin
tyler you are with brendan and eric all
right um
so it's a free though what do you say
he's a free dub yeah okay so
first up we'll go stevie versus brendan
oh is that what this is
yes wow i will ask i will ask the
question
and then say your name to buzz in and
then the first person
to uh say their name will get the first
crack at the board how does porkchop not
have a fake mustache
uh it's come on i don't think carter
all right what do you got uh we asked a
hundred married men
top seven answers are on the board what
is something you enjoy
watching your wife doing brendan oh
come on um i'm working out
yeah that's not on the board really
i guess can i go no no no because now
someone down no it's not stevie
and this is for control of the board and
then oh i get it actually don't wait
on family feud they actually do go down
the we have three chances don't we but
the first guess
is for controlling oh yeah that's right
okay you're right
oh i got one okay so
stevie uh doing laundry
i'll actually judges are actually going
to count it the last answer is
clean that ain't doing laundry
the weeby's got control over the board
you got to leave that up there uh yeah
we leave the clean part but take off the
number
we can see and then for the next
question you'll put them back up yeah
yeah you're young you're young yeah
young pieces okay now
it is chinster i'm gonna say a shower
there you go yeah well yeah pervert i
get it
you guys were misogynistic he's like
work out clean
no i said laundry i said laundry oh even
worse
it's still their turn uh yeah now it is
carrister they get up to three x's
no i was gonna say cook
[Applause]
wow that's not number one
wow cook clean i
all right uh back to stevie i got
another one
they only have one they have two they go
down the line into oh they have no x's
actually oh
at the moment jesus they'll be lost
we're gonna give them three though it's
gonna take forever huh
uh all right two not if we're good
what about making love
are you a cuck steve
[Laughter]
[Applause]
get [ __ ] by a big black guy
[Music]
it might be a personal thing but eating
yeah
yeah make a sandwich or cook
cook's already on there so
yes so you guys uh get one chance to
steal
the griffins and you guys can talk
amongst yourselves tyler brennan
we didn't get to talk usa no because you
had control oh that's fine no
i was gonna say uh play with the kids
play with the kids that's good too yeah
play play with the kids
being a mother or something so dance or
being married but that don't mean you
got kids
so i was just going to go with the
savior oh true it true what's your
answer
dance you want to go with dance oh
you're going to put that on me man
yeah yeah yeah you came in talking [ __ ]
we got to put it on here
now do we get to do the other part where
you have to do like that fast money
yeah we're gonna do two more questions
and then oh now you have to do that
thing they do on family feud
you have to go like six hours
number six and we have to say it yep
[Applause]
oh number one is definitely take a [ __ ]
god who made this list yeah i like to
watch my girl sleep i like it there's
100 people surveyed what they answered
that's not creepy eric
it's my girl and number one
yeah i knew it undressed okay that was
gonna be the first one
yeah wow yeah you guys i said she was
like
making love that's the same thing yeah
so we should fix them but i wanted the
undressing i just wanted to save it
okay so the uh the griffin jobs have 49
points
oh okay uh he said who's winning
we are getting shot we just stole that
round dude
we stole that from you with your dumb
answers with your
[ __ ] answer all right so uh while
he's setting up we'll do a king in her
sting it
what's up brandon what's up just
chilling on the beach what's up on the
floor of amaline
mom i'm just recording the video for
kind of this thing okay give me a second
did you say mom thinking or sting it
maybe it's the kfc and i don't really
know it's 11 13 am i've had
five new cultures my mom's had a truly
i think she's still a little a little
tipsy so keep interesting
drinking with your fam on vacation dang
gang buzz buzz
let's go okay first of all
drinking with your family on vacation is
one thing drinking with your mom
on vacation is a completely different
thing yeah all right it's all
at 11 a.m yeah yeah you're on the beach
with your mom
i was always jealous of the families
that would drink together the parents
really not me but not like when you have
to go like this
give me two [ __ ] seconds what the mom
was like
tell brendan i said hi
[Laughter]
uh you drink with your family stevie i'm
sober i don't drink
that's right yeah do you drink i don't
drink no
yeah no you don't you know what you know
as far as i forgot steve me too
and then i brought him wine to his
birthday you did yeah and i was like
and as soon as you looked at me you were
like what what the [ __ ]
yeah i don't know that was stupid just
it's a tough business to be in you're
literally performing at a bar yeah
you're basically a bar restaurant yeah
like you're around it
yeah if you've got an eating disorder or
you don't want to be like working at
dunkin donuts yeah you know what i mean
he was cool though
you could perform like is does it help
your set like just to get a little bit
time i drink you can't looser that no
but you saw me i don't get like okay but
even still
wanted to be a crutch no it's not all
right no not at all all right no yeah
so icebreaker just to get on stage uh
not even that it's just like i never
drink except for now
when i'm on the road so it's like this
is like family feud mixed with
intervention right now
yeah and then actually we have some
people to talk to you come on out guys
your mom's like it's about time
oh you'll be different right no that's
that's so dark
sting
give the person a chance this guy's a
wild man uh-huh
what's good brendan what's good theo man
cat studios
how y'all doing man i gotta say i got
much love and respect for y'all i'm a
longtime fan
i go by ace man florida amigo straight
ahead temp but you know we be wilding
yeah you know we be wilding so don't
even judge my hair
ignore that [ __ ] i don't let the
elephant in the room but no no it's not
no you're you're pierced the elephant
yeah yeah yeah
this is a herd of elephants
you know what i'm saying this is like
jumanji right here okay
here's the least of my friends it's it's
your jargon
your fake chain dude this guy came on
the screen and it was like a
what dude
jumanji i don't see elephant in a room
god all right let's finish this guy this
guy's great
i'm here by the way by the way real
quick he's in tampa so we got to hook
him up with cara
[Laughter]
she unfortunately cannot see him at the
moment
you're missing now this guy
he looks like a member of that band who
sings come my lady come come my lady
no no uh so i know you're talking about
this is it some
are you thinking i'm thinking of some
41.41
no i'm thinking about my lady come on
butterfly
and they did like all the drugs in the
world and then he was on celebrity rehab
oh wow not surprised yeah all right
let's see what else he is finished with
this guy
crazy town this guy's
is listening to uh
comedy podcast why are you being active
y'all getting too funny
i love y'all man i do like this guy yeah
yeah he's a good guy i do like that yeah
you know what he's always saying
he's authentic yeah he's not fake yeah
and his video was literally two and a
half minutes i cut it down but he talked
about how he was he was trying to bench
press
60s and he almost dropped him when theo
was talking about stevie's urban ass
so he thinks it's uh it's unsafe too
this is a comedy podcast while you're
like working out
yeah i don't really i don't listen to
comedy podcasts when i'm working out or
not i mean i don't want to say any other
comedy podcast yeah that's not music
it's just music i'd never listen to
music i listen to audiobooks audiobooks
uh listen to like uh the
they were with the hill rogan had them
on they're like supposed to be in the
middle
you know what i'm saying they wear the
hill i forget their name
they're too political like one's a
conservative one's like the liberal but
they
they always meet in the middle like
they're not like cnn or fox i'll listen
to that
just to get a temperature on what's
going on yeah yeah that's good that's
good
but if you can't but that guy seems like
he gets distracted by things so i don't
know if he should be
if he should be working out no i don't
think he should have headphones on yeah
yeah
he needs to stay focused so sting it
stand stand hard sting all right back to
the feud
uh we've got eric and chin
for control of the board talking chin
now
yeah whoever says whoever says their
name first oh yeah
we asked a hundred people top eight
answers are on the board
who would be the worst person to
accidentally send a naked selfie to
chin [ __ ] i gotta be honest though i saw
one of the answers so i'm not gonna say
that answer
are you all right thanks for being
honest jen but then also
who kind of [ __ ] you the whole time
hold on
just don't say it for this and then you
can say it the rest someone will get and
that means i get control of the board
because he already saw the answer so he
cheated so i get control of the board
mom
number one that's what i saw parents
number one that's all the problem
obviously yeah it solves the problem
you guys don't get a chance because he
had the number one answer so it goes to
the griffin shops
thank you all right tyler what's your
guess
um i'm gonna have to go with an ex
don't look
all right uh brandon uh grandparents
grandma grandpa
doesn't that count as parents though i
think yeah it wasn't on there i think
they all kind of [ __ ] up yeah yeah
yeah come on man
is it my son your parents though yeah
but still it's in the same vein you know
what i mean
it's him it's uh eric's dude
wait wait did tyler go yeah
it's not your turn i know
brendan how many answers are left uh oh
good good
guys there are five answers left jesus
tyler
the worst person to send a new to would
probably be uh
one of your guy friends one of your bros
yeah best friend well we lost
it you got it there's uh four more
brandon
um
best friend um i mean as my kids get
older as a parent that would
blow ass to send a dick pic to my kid
can't argue with that and the fact that
you're even sending a dick pic is
the two lisa's alarming two reasons
oh my gosh okay all right you guys got
only one x still you could run out the
board uh
eric oh wow we've already got all the
good ones on here we got parents we got
eggs we got boss we got kids we got best
friend
um who else would just
not want to send a dick pic to huh uh
yeah maybe i'll like two more for you if
you can't get it maybe like you're uh
that's my answer yeah uh maybe it's like
honestly
you're you're you're like you're priest
or rabbit
that's insane there you go i own you
cara
i'm in your head woman we got two more
tyler clearly
um i'm gonna go with like a teacher or
professor
oh schooling y'all this is what happened
what happened
also oh something's wrong it is on there
it isn't it's not
no oh one more guess one more guess
that you it's you brendan right um what
was it on there teacher i'll say like a
coach
a coach a coach
you can take over this dude terrible
answer hey man it's family feud you're
like okay that's all right
that's all right it should be on let's
try it
so that's it for us yes chance
good luck who's next uh you guys can
talk amongst yourself
i already i know i have one for sure
okay chen if you have it for sure you
don't have to leave the room
i'm 100
just to talk it out what's your idea
cara
mine yeah this isn't wait
this is i stole all yours already oh no
it's okay it doesn't matter it doesn't
you guys yeah
we won't have a turn on social media
oh on social media yeah go check okay
sibling yeah brother or sister yeah
there's no way
number three
[Music]
yeah i do yeah you know i sound like
some losers right now
good job now you won nick we should have
played wheel of fortune
uh yeah without a giant wheel let it go
woman
let it go without a giant wheel wheel
unfortunately it's just happening i
can't do it
very good you don't want to see pork
chop in a [ __ ] dress either wait
there's an
another how is brother or sister not on
there i know you're making
no sense what would you say can you
imagine how is that not only
dude that's so bright
in the third round they won't be able to
pass it so the griffin shops go to fast
money
yeah well we'll have all three people
uh just tim tebow jerseys good luck
thanks cara
thank you guys i know only time tim
tebow's been good luck for anything then
you must not be a florida gator fan sir
or a denver bronco fan
sadly i'm a falcons fan so i can't
really tell you recorded
oh you're a falcons fan yes i have like
you guys suck
man hey we lost julio and we're kind of
screwed uh
even more so than what we were you still
got matt ryan
what's up you guys still got matt ryan
yeah i believe so
yeah all right that's not really helping
much but yeah
just older so time to play fast money
i think all three of us can play but um
we'll have tyler go first and you guys
how does it work you guys shouldn't
listen
to his answers yeah that's not supposed
to work i mean
you know we're not even supposed to be
in the room yeah that's true let's just
uh
do all three of you want to guess at
fast money yeah this
because it's silly if we like compete
for answers then our time's just gonna
go like way the [ __ ] down
yeah yeah yeah first question this man
knows you different this guy knows his
[ __ ]
oh i told nick man i grew up in the
midwest these kind of game shows is like
only seconds in the nba finals
bro and high school football i'm
surprised nba finals is that high in
your list
oh well i mean i grew up in indiana
there's not much other than that
when you're a kid i know how i can do it
uh tyler will go first
uh you guys will not be able to hear him
and then you guys will go second
oh together tight move ah nice all right
nick
all right nick the producer uh
we go now name a public place where you
see parents disciplining their children
the mall name a place you should never
stick your finger
an outlet name a place where
you keep pictures of your loved ones um
on the wall
give me one word to describe someone who
gets on your nerves
hanoi last one name of food that you
hope
that you hope you got milk to go with
cookies boom good good job
all right here we go i'm ready
y'all got it that's all yo name a public
place where you see parents
disciplining their children
sorry sorry yeah we'll start we'll start
with brown amusement park
name a place you should never stick your
finger
socket uh uh he tyler picked that
oh um uh the garbage disposal
name a place where you keep pictures of
your loved ones
wallet
give me one word to describe someone who
gets on your nerves annoying
theo ink oh annoying was taken
frustrating okay name a food that you
hope you got milk to go with
cereal donuts serious okay cause i
thought he was gonna say siri i'm
surprised cereal's the number one answer
yeah for sure
i went with cookies he went with cookies
uh
number one cereal number one answer uh
cookies is 20
21. you guys got 81 so far um
name a public place where you see
parents disciplining their children we
said
i want to say walmart but too specific
uh
what were the two um mall and
amusement park boom what's up dog maul's
number one answer
ooh do we wanna
count amusement park's not on there
that's [ __ ]
57. you've never been to disneyland then
we need 100 to get win to ten thousand
two hundred two hundred two hundred two
one oh
and tyler's on it hey man i'm telling
you i know this [ __ ]
name a place where you should never
stick your finger light soccer's number
one answer that's 62.
oh we're close and what was the other
garbage disposal
garbage disposal is four so 66.
not bad name a place where you keep uh
pictures of your loved ones wallet
number one answer
23 and what you said on the wall on the
wall
11. that car would have been pretty high
what was the second i bet that photo
album was the second one photo album
yeah i mean guys what are you talking
about
give me one word to describe someone who
know uh who gets on your nerves annoying
was number one
28 and then what was the frustration
we got it done nope oh but you guys got
it
the total is and uh play the music if i
say a number over two hundred colin
328 oh my god wow
[Music]
all right thank you for coming to family
dude we will see you
next week
thanks tyler thank you good job tyler
you crushed it dog
we'll send you some merch text me your
address good job we'll send you some
cats merch man for being on the winning
side
appreciate it brother y'all talking
about thanks brother take it easy take
care eric you want a cat's merch
yeah sure yeah
good job guys thanks man we crashed you
guys huh yeah you did good
lame answers but whatever you should
have his and hers like one says sting
the other one says king you know
you know oh yeah buttons we've had them
and then batteries kept running out yeah
and then we just hit him for no reason
oh damn piece uh she was one of the
people in our
cat's facebook group who participated in
the roast me channel
queen of the dragons holla uh and
let's listen to some of her roasts and
if you want me to pause and you got one
of your own feel free
to let me have me pause hi theo hi
brendan this is shelby from nebraska and
i am going to read some roasts for you
guys
first one is from casey thomas looks
like that fanny pack is hiding the dick
that matches those feet
[Laughter]
is she a porn star no she's from harry
potter yeah
that statement is definitely true i love
pop tarts
um arien fuchsia says i don't know if i
should seems like she might cast a spell
on me
very smart thinking on your part jack
declan of selena gomez
was buried in pet cemeteries
hanging upside down
i definitely wish i could you look like
your parents are proud
they definitely are not proud and i
really wish they were wayne boyd
says you look like you shoplifting
travis jose anderson what kind of ssris
you got
in that fanny pack we don't have any
ssris in that fanny pack even though i
probably should so if you know any good
ones please let me know
i'm barely hanging on here uh you look
like you call cutting hair and art
stephen ray wood
that is true i am a barber oh wow that's
the closest thing to art that i'm
good at so thank you for that i look
like
you i tell guys hpv isn't a big thing
i would definitely tell a guy that if i
had to anybody
plan b michael shelton
i should probably have my fanny pack but
i don't and then the last one here is
from joy
every time she lies her toes
probably true i have really long toes
especially for a lady
these are the toes in question um i
think it was a bad angle but
you know i if this internet says i have
long toes i have long toes
she's a good sport yes she's great yeah
yeah yeah honey thank you for the help
she's dope
good for herself out there man they let
her up yeah yeah
cemetery that was fun all right
a couple more king editor stingets to
close it out okay
hey brendan my name is avery and i'm
from austin texas
and i have a king interesting it for you
jennifer lopez and ben affleck getting
back together
what do we think is it really weird or
are all of our early 2000
rom-com dreams finally coming true let
me know what you think
a hard king i love bennett
those days are done he got lit up when
uh they showed his back tattoo on the
beach
yeah but i mean like he's just you know
when he got the most eight when he was
batman
no no he got almost hate when he was
daredevil oh see i enjoyed daredevil oh
boiler room was good yeah he's he's
already won an oscar
goodwill hunting he was good in goodwill
hunting yeah he's got he's yeah
the town yeah i think that these two are
like
later in life now they've dealt with a
lot of stuff they have a familiarity
that they've had from before and now
they're just now they know
you know they got their own money and
they're just like you know what let's do
this [ __ ] king it
hard king it yeah that's king that is
that picture of yeah ben affleck
grabbing her ass too
yeah dude good for him do that just do
it
they're good you know they're dealing
with it i mean that's when relationships
actually work because now they're not
just lovers they're friends
yeah they're partners you know when
they're mature maybe she was the one
that got away then she did her thing
with a-rod
yeah yeah yeah all right king it big
fans ben affleck over here
he has some dope ass movies he's a good
actor that movie where he plays the
i like the accountant he plays that
gangster and then they send him to tampa
bay
you know what i'm talking about that's a
good movie he doesn't miss man
yeah he's great
what up boys ryan here from whistler
british columbia
mike swift club for you dudes who
guarded so
i built this veggie garden in my
backyard for my girlfriend and i last
year but i'm the one who really just
does the planting and harvesting
nothing better brother i get super
stoked because these little jumbo
zucchini has been coming oh look at
look at that get the wrong ideas and
start sticking them in places they don't
belong
cucumbers oh hell yes freaking cucumbers
there
oh yeah yeah full-blown whole foods yeah
super hyped and i got these chili
peppers coming in
every day i come out here so what's
what's he saying interesting you're
saying guarding him for bro
he's not that's not even just guard he's
a farmer dude
that's amazing dude guys that's a
from farm to throat
if you do have like a lawn a garden
nothing's more relaxing right my ficuses
i take so much pride in my ficuses
they're getting [ __ ]
big
he should be proud of him nothing like a
dude you know you're a dad when you care
about your life oh yeah
like dude my lawn's everything man
yeah it looks great i love cutting the
lawn love the smell of it
hard king yeah that's a big that is it
all right
yeah thank you yeah all right kids i'll
be in tacoma this week thursday friday
saturday
august 19th through the 21st i'm in
north carolina north cacalaca
all right but this week is tacoma get
your tickets
at thickboy.com or fatkz.com
eric yeah just go to eric griffin.com i
got a bunch of stuff coming up i'm going
to be in
chicago at the den theater i'm going to
be
where are all my i'm going to be
actually the next thing i'm doing is i'm
going to be in vegas at the
mgm grand at brad garrett's comedy club
i'll be there all week
that'd be fun yeah so i'm doing that
people loved you when you
uh surprised them came and did sets at
the haha with me oh yeah that was fun
yeah we had a good time
yeah it was a good time good times there
that was fun yeah we got to get more
crossover man kinging and riffing and
kinging
yeah and fightering yeah for real
all right thanks guys youtube.com slash
scissor pros get you some god damn it
he
[Music]
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ain't the queso and the
quesoritos but
everything's gonna be fine hate on me i
do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brendan's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in a club can you pick me up
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you